in this video I'm introducing two more
algebraic laws for sets associativity
and commutativity associativity is
essentially just saying that we can
regroup the sets that we are talking
about so a intersection b intersection c
that is a intersecting with the set b
intersection c is equal to the set a
intersection b intersection c and
if you look at the definitions of
intersection you can actually go through
and figure out why this is and i'm
pretty sure you'll be able to do that
based on the videos that you've already
watched and the same is true for the
union community is essentially just
saying that we can switch which side our
sets are relative to the operations so a
intersection B is the same thing as B
intersection a and the same thing is a
union B is equal to B Union a so if we
look at the actual definition we have a
intersection B is defined as the set
containing elements X such that X is an
element of a and X is an element of B
and that's going to equal the set
containing elements X such that X is an
element of B and X is an element of a so
if you just look at these the conditions
for these for the set builder notation
here it's essentially just a argument of
grammar at this point so basic English
will tell you that you can just switch
which side that you have to join